ivan chagnaud vous propose voyage sans
passeport
et
singapour singapour babel moderne dont
le nom se retrouve dans toutes les
aventures extrême orientale et qui ne
vit que de la mer singapour aussi est un
porc et c'est aussi un port de pêche
c'est pourquoi vous voyez ces flottilles
rentrée chargée de poissons multicolores
poisson qui constitue la base de la
nourriture soit qu'il soit consommé
frais soit c'est chez le porc aux gens
est une des premières visites que doit
faire le touriste organise ces barques
sont de véritables villes flottantes
car la vivent les familles des pêcheurs
vous voyez saisir sa chance
bien que ses vues et été prise en 59 par
grandmaison voyez-vous le drapeau
britannique flotte encore sur certains
building ou à côté de certains building
est cependant l'indépendante a eu lieu
le 8 février 56 dans le cadre du
commonwealth et cette indépendance a été
confirmé en 57 par la grande bretagne
qui fit don de keng et de malacca
le port de commerce à un trafic colossal
et et nous allons dans un instant visité
ensemble la ville chinoise
e
pour l'instant c'est la faute idée
peut-être de la police voici la ville
chinoise et vous le verrez tout à
l'heure c'est une véritable course
certains tout au moins quoi sans
véritable cour des miracles asiatiques
c'est un monde étrange coloré
dont les élections surprennent souvent
le jour b 1
la foule est intense bruyante et aux
portes des boutiques des masques des
lampions toutes sortes d'ornementation
et c'est ce petit personnage si proche
de la vie qu'on ne sait où est la part
du rêve en l ou en nous mais ce petit
personnage va nous permettre la jonction
avec kuala lumpur
voilà le bourg où chaque pays a sa
politique celle de la malaisie
permettez-moi bien modestement poulard
ac mali est maintenant une monarchie
constitutionnelle
singapour devient une colonie séparer de
la couronne en 46 l'union de la malaisie
puis fait le premier visé 48 et le 8
février 56 fut proclamé l'indépendance
dans le cadre du commonwealth
indépendance comme je viens de vous le
dire qu'il a été confirmé en 57 phare la
grande bretagne qui ajoutait à singapour
hong kong et malacca et devant vos yeux
la rentrée du parlement une consoeur des
personnalités et parmi ces personnalités
le défunt roi premier de la malice abdul
rahman livni tuanku mizan magne vous
vous le rappelez nous voici le roi a
décidé le 1er avril 1960 il avait été
consacré le 2 septembre 57 après avoir
été élu chef suprême le 3 août
57 son remplaçant a été élu pour cinq
ans par le parlement
et il a pour nom there is a mean à la
mouche à mais voici et cérémonie de
l'ouverture du parlement en 59
oui c'est notre ambassadeur de france
et je lui dirai ce qui hier était venu
voir comment se déroulait la cérémonie
kuala lumpur au matin baignée de bruits
des toits de la radio malaise
et si nous faisions un léger retour en
arrière il y as exactement 70 ans
kuala lumpur était un petit village
installé juste en bordure de la jongle
et vivent sur deux mecs aux plantations
de manioc dont les habitantes irène
tapioca aujourd'hui vous voyez la
capitale solennelle qu'elle est devenue
c'est un curieux mélange d'un urbanisme
moderne et de construction d'autres
siècles
donc là
tous
la circulation est assez intense le
coiffeur se trouve en pleine rue c'est
assez agréable au fonds de se faire
coiffer d'une façon aussi à l'airé
m
on se fait coiffer à tout achat kuala
lumpur ont ni coq est très très jeune
vous savez
et puis voilà le stade lemaire des cas
stadium de colas lumpur
aujourd'hui il se remplit de musulmans
venus prier ma remettre dont c'est
l'anniversaire de la naissance est la
même date à 15000 kilomètres de la
france où vote anti sel et vieux quand
il de la nativité le peuple mallet
fêtait son noël sous l'ardent soleil en
s'asseyant dans une tribune et en
écoutant la lecture du coran
voici l'avenir du pays
il en est du reste ainsi de tout pays
sa jeunesse un mariage et c'est avec ces
jeunes ces enfants que la malaisie
construira son avenir de nouvelles
nations indépendantes avec eux se bâtir
à l'unité du pays sa prospérité sa force
malek chinois indiens vivent ensemble
leurs parents étaient du sumatra de java
de colombo de pékin de karachi mais eux
se retrouvent chaque jour dans la même
école
vous allez les voir
pour mme affecte leur type et pau
détendue voici une petite école
absorbent l'eau perdue dans la jambe une
dans les rieurs vous voyez tous les
enfants du monde sur sambre
quand la classe et finissent d'acquis
chorale plus vite pour aller y jouer on
rentre vous le remarquerez bon peu plus
calmement
une courte visite au victorienne collège
de kuala lumpur établissement chic de la
fédération c'est en quelque sorte
hidden ou une sorte d'icône pour être
plus précise
on y joue un football spécial
la balle est en osier tressé
c'est un sport très répandu en malaisie
mais qui nécessite beaucoup beaucoup
d'aces
on
les bâtiments sont de modernisme
audacieux
là où s'élevait hier la jambe que l'on
disait imprenable se trouve l'université
malaise comme un site magnifique et à
deux pas de cette université se
construit la première nouvelle ville de
malaisie et aline jaya qui sera capable
d'abriter demain près de cent mille
personnes et adghigh à est à juste titre
la fierté des malaises
les villas sont espacées les unes des
autres
très coquette et pour un prix
relativement faible le mal est peut
acquérir sa maison toujours entourée
d'un jardin voici les rues puisqu'on n'y
a pas encore de maison mais ça ne s'en
était remis
quant au jardin vous êtes d'accord avec
moi c'est fort appréciable la semaine
prochaine nous poursuivrons notre voyage
en alice
inch allah vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de henry de grandmaison
et de solange péters montage pierre
michel rey script lui cet embryon sont
claude gilles sion illustration sonore
dominique fall a dit
e